hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the sims 4 now everybody
and I mean everybody wanted me to play
this what is going on right there
did she just die why anyway I'm gonna
play it in just one episode i'm gonna
create me Bob and Wade put us in a house
together and see what happens and make
them regret that I am the deity that
rules over their existence let's get to
it I'm gonna I need to make them first
I haven't even loaded up the sims 4 oh
hello there on your way to looking like
Bob so I guess I'll start with Bob here
alright default wha
what different walks what in the world
is that I'm saving that for Wade yeah
maybe this should be his walk cuz he's
always tired of the [ __ ] than me and
Wade put him through oh yeah oh man this
is cool not really but cool ok
Oh whoo hee whoo key alright then that
that oh well then yes and no at the same
time very yes and very no nope no no no
no what am i doing no no no well how do
I look a little smile on him he's ducky
little dere we get ya he's not that
happy remember he has to deal with us
all day so yeah let's bring that a
little down oh oh God
oh oh god what in the world a music
lover
[Music]
yeah that was those gorgeous there Bob
you keep doing that cuz that's good oh
god I get one stubbly little chicken
legs Oh
his feet are tiny Oh his feet are ugly
tiny why are they tiny okay whatever
um the damage has been done looking good
there Bob except for your tiny feet okay
the chaps are a nice touch
love the robe okay I made Bob that took
forever Wade has the shrill voice that's
exactly what I hear when Wade talks oh
yeah it looks like wait I think maybe a
bobbin that he's gonna forgive me when
he sees this if you Oh No
yeah there we go that that's definitely
wait that's the wait I know and love
this haven't looked away - I know and
love
oh yeah yeah that's there yup that
sounds about right
bring the eyes down now bring the eyes
up and together as much as possible
there we go those suckers back down
there no way up there tears that's good
let's see bring that up there and no
he's happy he's a Beezus yeah Oh Wade
you've never looked better
yeah he's got very very pretty whoa whoa
okay then whoa oh wow oh wow oh wow okay
then
that is so Wow Wade oh boy oh boy oh boy
whoa I should stop messing with
perfection goodnight boy there I love
you strong jaw
I'm gonna only look at you from the back
cuz that's the only kind of semblance of
normal whoa loving the cowboy boots with
the robe but not sure that kind of goes
together there wait oh wait you've never
looked better
actually a lot of times you've looked
better but those boots man those boots
how do I get the scraggly not quite full
half beard can I just have that can I
have that mustache please oh I would
love it I got those eyes that just make
you not want to trust anyone I got those
full luscious lips it's so kissable I
got the jawline for days the high
cheekbones and whatnot they slightly
upturned I the really I look a lot like
my mom except with a mustache right now
okay not like No yes yes handsome
Squidward oh yes but you can't even tell
the difference between the two of us Oh
Dora indeed you're looking so good
you're fit too oh yeah oh you're so
something you're something you're a
whole lot of something me okay let's
recap for everyone who hasn't been
paying attention and or if I skipped
ahead because that took forever this is
Bob he is a computer whiz who is
cheerful music lover and ambitious oh
he's just a spitting image this is Wade
he wants to be friends with the world
he's clumsy hates children and is insane
spitting image of it he's got great
boots too this is me markiplier I am a
joke star I'm outgoing geeky and
creative and as you can see we're all
the spitting image of ourselves so now
that that took forever I'm gonna
actually play the game now I actually
really do like the Sims game I played
every single one of them with quite a
lot oh hello where are we oh can we move
into a trailer park please please tell
me we can alright here we go
yay could this be the perfect home a
playing spot of grass perfect well do
our charity livestreams and everything
it has so much fun
there's some features in us shut up I
know how to play oh shut up shut up shut
up shut up shut up shut up shut up I
know up I know shut up jack boss shut up
oh that's cool you can build rooms buy
rooms now that'll be roomy room roomy
all right yes good
I said that's way that's Bob's room
there skip a belittle book space
that's good that's good I like that I
like that a lot
nope nope there we go
most excellent okay now Wade room all
right let's see he gets the green one
cuz that's who we be oh I need a rotate
that one see ya I need that much space
yeah looks good to me okay so that's
there that's good okay so the bathroom
very easily goes through Wade's room and
that way he has ready access to the
bathroom that is good for him
we are very nice to wait here okay so
for our computer desks which are very
important we need some serious hardware
and then Wade needs something not so
serious so we got our chairs here ooh
the boss executive chair that is very
nice what else do we have
ah yes another one for me and then the
kinder main chair excellent exactly what
Wade wants thank you so much game you
are awesome
okay we're on a bit of a budget but we
want to have decent decent desktops for
us and then Wade gets by he does okay
for himself that's all the necessities I
can think of so we're ready to live
right that only took forty five goddamn
minutes do we need Windows I don't know
a damn person that needs a window but we
probably need a door to get in our place
and thing that's
maybe I like where's the doors I needed
oh there we go
[Music]
that seems good enough to me alrighty
then I think we're good to go
oh we're alive yay okay Bob wants to do
some over there Wayne I are standing
around okay there we go apparently
we're off to do some there that's not
our walks oh that's yeah that's our
walks that is exactly our walk so there
we go it was this different one we ran
wide wide wait get off of there
wait no no wait hey hey hey talk to
yourself just wait
goddammit stand the corner talk to
yourself wait stop talking about
unicorns oh my goodness wait going the
corner wait going the corner and talk to
yourself please thank you very much Wade
okay Bob is making his way downtown
moving fast walking past way then he's
gone bad
Wade you you have the best time over
there okay so everything seems to be
going as normal or as expected we're all
on the computer ignoring all of our
other basic needs until we fall over and
pass out
sounds like my life already okay I can't
take it anymore we're all gonna find
jobs because I cannot have you guys
standing around each other for one more
second
no Wade oh my god Wade you are so being
an astronaut okay bob is gonna be a
criminal mastermind because that's
pretty close to his current career I'm
just gonna play video games all day
every day because that's what I do right
now
oh my god one awaits aspirations is be
mean to a child that's so cool oh my god
a cupcake factory hell yeah all that
looks so cool oh my god if this was
actually available I would buy one in a
heartbeat are you kidding me
cupcake factory cupcake factory Pig
something I don't care bake it I want
cupcakes bad time okay did it just fart
out cupcakes can I just say that this is
very strange watching Bob take a bath
all right okay
oh my goodness
oh we're rich we're rolling in money for
no apparent reason of course you guys
can't see what I'm doing
not that I'm doing anything Bob the
butler fancy statue well that's not at
all terrifying I love that right outside
our door
can I have oh my god yes wake up
markiplier you'll never get out of your
bed now fire light bar Y Z Z wake up you
have a special summoning waiting for you
wait how about I get you a gift list a
baron von bigger bong I love Puss
appearing fun figure pong he's gonna
camp out the restroom he's gonna help us
all go to the bathroom more efficiently
so many gnomes we need so many gnomes
yes the rocket ship apparently can't
place that inside so we'll place that
outside we're gonna have the best toilet
oh they're just the best when the Baron
von Google Homer would be proud of Oh
only the best for me and Bob and then
only the mediocre for Wade I wouldn't
have it any other way
oh good thing that we found all this
money buried in the backyard among all
those bones we found but that's okay
we're gonna do just fine the landlord
whisper ha ha ah you clever bastards
well it's gonna be good but other crap
do they have art yes art of course how
can I forget the art it looks arty art
beright there are there oh god it's art
by itself just having all this art gonna
be so cultured I don't know what the
hell this is but I want it grow
oh yeah grill right by the bathroom
perfect place wha every part of this
place is beautiful let's live it live in
the moment
do I have to build that myself wait wait
I have a job for you stop sleeping build
a rocket ship shut up I don't care if
you're uncomfortable the damn rocket
ship Bob get up you're gonna grill us
awesome
grellus all hamburgers can now build
rocket ships well then wait is now
officially a rocket scientist so there's
not to look for doing Wow it's so cool
it's like cooking with plasma oh yes
this is a fire hazard
I don't care yeah that's a fire hazard
fire that's not like Bob after being
literally on fire he goes to play video
games on the computer and then takes a
bath that's kind of badass that Bob is
wait you're in I don't care Bob's in
there just use it we're all friends no
we're all friends come on it's okay all
right fine you're practically insane
what does it matter
weight is literally gonna pee can you
pee in the fountain wait okay wait just
wet himself all over the floor
[Music]
go meet that lady she looks cute
friendly be friendly I stink like the
dickens I have to pee this is the most
confident walk-up I've ever seen and
apparently Bob's coming to record this
interaction between me and this lovely
lady over here hello hi you're pretty I
smell bad I also have to go don't mind
the order it's okay Bob thank you you're
my best wingman you have you do great am
i talking to you or the lady I don't
know Bob you're standing a little close
to the lady there I'm Bob what in the
world are you even doing here Bob I'm
having a conversation with this lovely
lady here I'm very uncomfortable but I
really want to get to know her so pop
you could just leave
panca Bob Bob don't interject into the
conversation go talk bop-bop-bop go talk
with that lady Bob Bob Bob Bob go talk
with that lady okay Bob struck out and I
peed myself 100 so I don't know I've
been playing for like two and a half
hours now so I'm gonna cut it here this
is the sims 4 and this is probably the
only episode I would ever play of this I
might do a livestream of it but don't
count on it this was actually a lot of
fun I did enjoy myself and the only
reason I played for two and a half hours
is because I was having fun um if you
want to try the game you got to go
through origin to do it and I know a lot
of people don't like origin I would have
it rather be on Steam but hey this is me
so if you want to play the game you know
where to find it so anyway thank you all
so much for watching and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
Oh